I have to destroy uh Ben Shapiro with
facts and logic last week on his show he
talked about the UFO hearings on Capitol
Hill he hit exactly the same kind of
dismissive attitude
that
you would expect and it's the same
attitude that everybody here at DW has
except me
um and originally I'd plan to go through
in great detail and dissect everything
that he said about this and we're not
going to do that instead I just want to
call attention to two brief parts of
Ben's offensive and outrageous attack on
the alien believing Community ABC and uh
I think we have those clips let's play
the first one
alrighty folks Congress is so effective
that they have time to spare and now
they're having a hearing about UFOs
there was a big hearing on the hill
about UFOs now you may ask why am I
covering this so far into the show
wouldn't that be like the number one
news no because it's bullcrap okay I'm
just gonna put out there right now there
are no aliens on planet Earth other than
perhaps Bernie Sanders there are no
aliens okay that there may be in the
universe they haven't found us yet okay
so
yeah first of all Bernie Sanders is not
an alien he's like some kind of Undead
he's like a zombie he's an undead kind
of uh thing that came out of the ground
or they dug out of the ground like an
orc but you are admitting Ben to begin
with and this you always hear this I I
love when saying the quiet part out loud
okay this is and you'll you'll always
hear this and usually it's it's a little
bit more uh subliminal but here he's
coming out and said admitting the
preconceived biases up front
admitting that he rules out the
possibility that any aliens could have
visited Earth before looking at the
evidence
what does that mean it means that
there's no evidence at all that could
possibly convince him
so then what what credibility does this
point of view have on this subject if
you are saying from the beginning you
know if I come to you and I say
I have evidence
that aliens have visited Earth I have
evidence and you say to me it doesn't
matter what your evidence is I don't
believe it I already don't believe it
well okay see when I show you the
evidence and then you say yeah that's
not convincing well you were already
committed to that response
you were openly committed to that
response before you looked at it
so your response to the evidence is
meaningless
um as opposed to my Approach which is
very open-minded
now yes am I certain that aliens exist
yes am I certain they've been to Earth
yes but I'm I'm also I'm open I'm open
okay I will listen to the arguments and
I will respond to them
um so I have the much more open-minded
uh and dare I say tolerant
um
and I would even say enlightened
perspective on the subject than Ben
Shapiro does but here's where we really
get to get down to it is with the next
clip watch this
weird how that keeps happening how like
all of these systems that would provide
for the surveillance are they always go
down just like Bigfoot so many people
have seen Bigfoot and yet uh and yet
nobody seems to have gotten like a
really credible good view of Bigfoot
that they can then show like we only uh
we're on a planet where everyone has a
cell phone like every single person with
camera capabilities and you're telling
me that no one has yet taken credible
images of any of this magically that's
just that's just how it works
no it's not what we're telling you Ben
that's not what we're telling you in
fact there are a lot of credible images
this is not like Bigfoot okay at this
point I'm convinced that the people here
especially why we keep making this big
foot comparison they're doing it just to
attack me personally they're doing it
just to annoy me personally because this
the comparison
in fact the comparison only proves why
the alien stories are more credible
because yes with Bigfoot if you've got
this race of ape-like men who live in
the woods in North America they're in
your backyard practically uh and they've
been there for forever you'd think that
there'd be some kind of compelling video
footage photograph uh physical evidence
something and none of that exists so
that's enough to tell you that that the
whole story is bogus
with aliens first of all you wouldn't
even expect as much compelling evidence
because these are creatures that live
many light years away and if they visit
their fat their 50 000 feet in the sky
traveling at the speed of sound okay
whereas the Bigfoot is this big hairy
thing lumbering along and so there's a
lot of opportunity to grab your phone
and you could the Bigfoot's walking by
you could grab your phone your phone
could be off and this is how crap I
gotta turn it on and you take the time
to turn it on you pull the camera up and
Bigfoot's still there because he's so
slow and fat and dumb
but with with with the UFO blink and you
miss it and so there's not most times
not enough time to even pull your phone
out because the thing's traveling so
fast and yet in spite of those obstacles
still we have hundreds and hundreds and
hundreds of photographs footage that
we've seen since the 50s I mean there
are compelling uh UFO photos back in the
50s that still have not been debunked
people want to say that they're hoaxes
but many of them still people have been
you know experts have been looking at
them for decades and haven't been able
to debunk them
um and so what do you expect you expect
that
if if UFOs have visited uh you would
expect that in you know back in the mid
20th century when there was there's
photographic technology but not like it
is today that every once in a while
you'd see a good photograph and then you
would expect that today there'd be a lot
more and that's exactly what we see okay
it's exactly what we see and not only do
we have we have cell phone footage we
have radar okay we have data from radar
we have
um we have videos that Navy Pilots have
taken
where they are where they are up in the
sky and they are zooming in on a thing
that is traveling across the sky and
doing things that defy the laws of
physics is we understand them
Ben we have all of this it's there for
you to look at
okay but you refuse to you're not going
to see it if you have your eyes closed
and I think that's the issue here
so your response is well is this if this
was really happening then uh wouldn't
there be you know you'd think you'd have
uh Pilots or up in the sky and they see
this stuff and they get footage of it we
do have that
it's there
that's the whole point that's why we're
talking about this
okay what's your explanation Ben
how do you explain
what we can definitely say are physical
objects in the sky
doing things that
are
centuries beyond the technological
capabilities of this of of of of our
country
so was it do the Chinese are they are
they are they like 500 years ahead of us
with technology
and if they are why haven't they just
simply taken over the whole world by now
why haven't they just done that why
isn't that why isn't it the the whole
globe China if they have that kind of
Technology okay these are questions you
can't answer anyway the real question
Ben is not whether
there is reason to believe okay the
question is whether you are willing to
believe
are you willing to believe then
that's what you have to ask yourself in
your heart
hey YouTube thanks for listening to the
show if you'd like access to my full
show with no ads you should go to
dailywire.com and use promo code Walsh
to get two months free on all annual
plans see you there